le slow food en bon français manger
lentement c'est la philosophie d'une
association culturelle italienne un
congrès se tient actuellement à paris
sur cette initiative
nos voisins transalpins en lançant ce
message veulent essayer de convaincre
simultanément 21 pays sur les 5
continents qu'il vaut mieux prendre son
temps pour manger et pourquoi pas de la
cuisine régionale jambon sans daniel
blanc expurgeant à la sauce au fenouil
sauvage
les plats sont raffinées les
congressistes déguste chaque bouche ils
sont italiens ils se révoltent en
mangeant contre la tyrannie du faso où
ils ont inventé le slow food
parce que les ravioles mérite plus de
temps que l'on burger attendant quelque
chose qui n'est pas bon bombay ont fait
très bien l'art aller en vitesse un
chômage quelque chose qui est très bon
il faut avoir de l'époque des jeux jouir
du plaisir
les maîtres queux sont en toc les plats
authentiques n'y pas ni viande hachée
des trucs et des fumées avant toute
chose c'est le premier principe de ces
révolutionnaires de la table le service
aussi doit être élégant carmen dans
l'art de passer des plats il faut savoir
prendre son temps de cuisiner c'est la
cuisine même simple mêmes phrases
simples qui est pair avec des produits
très bonne deuxième principe adopté
autour des tables contre l'invasion
américaine il faut manger nationale hier
soir c'était hilaliens l'an prochain à
venise pour le 2e congrès on mangera
français le foie gras remplacera les
ravioles à moins qu il soit l'escargot
de bourgogne
celui que les congressistes ont choisi
comme symbole voilà bien des nues